so further graphs and markets before
luncheon of these these things this
topic right is part of our vision and
part new stuff
the further graphs is really actually
from the end of unite but because it's
actually after the exam so a lot of you
won't have gotten there maybe you're too
busy doing statistics and try and wrap
your head around standard deviation you
can pronounce this Lukas if you once I
pronounced some blockers because after
this many years of teaching of people
think huh we're learning about insects
that everything you look like
grasshoppers I'm like locusts okay so
you call that a meal so taro buys
because this is really the introduction
to that what are functions functions are
best understood in contrast to relations
functions and relations and I wonder if
any of those words ring a bell okay
what's a function it's a kind of rule
I'll write this down in a second
it's a kind of rule that for one input
gives you one output it's a kind of rule
so here's what I think about it you've
got a a box which is a rule okay you put
in one input and you'll get out one
output that is a function
okay so as an example y equals x squared
that's a function you put in any value
for X right
0 1 2 3 4 5 100 minus 100 and you get
out one output one night okay
so let's think real well what's an
example of this let's take a currency
conversion so if you had a box right
that could convert fancy imagine it was
a kind of currency converter but what it
does is it spits out it translates
everything into ozzie dollars okay so
you can put in anything you like you can
put in yen you can put in Riga or
remember whatever you want okay and you
get out what it is in our currency okay
so the whole idea is any infant you like
you just have it's only going to be
worth one particular value in Aussie
dollars okay so if I wait I don't know I
think the conversion is something like
because I'm through being it is about
what does he do
okay so so like 3-ring it could be one
time yeah what does it go up but
sometimes to Aussie dollars there's only
one possibility that you're gonna gather
what output might I trust
what's a relation a relation you go it's
it's a rule in the same way right when
you put an input into this okay the
outputs you get you may get one output
but you may get more
okay so it could just be one but there
might be multiple as well that's a
relation okay now I'd picked y equals x
squared as an example because it's I can
pick up a relation off that just by
reversing things and that's going to
help your flames episode if I take just
swapping it around say x equals y
squared that's a relation okay how does
it work if I put in an input for X right
like say 9 okay
my output will be not just one but
there's two different options right what
I can't just be one thing can be 3 or
negative 3 right so that's where you've
got your more outputs so as an example
right come back to this currency idea so
prove as I reverse the question and say
I've got my currency converter but
instead of putting up as in dollars what
if I put in noisy dollars okay and try
and get different currencies so putting
one is posi dollar and say now what's
that equal to well there's all different
kinds of answers you could give me right
you could say it's 3 bingo or you could
say it's what's happened what's what do
we work with American I scroll in
Murdoch right so maybe you get under I
thought what's funny
ok so you can see I've got most of
different options here that's what we
mean by a relation okay what do these
things look like
there's your own sorry I'm just use your
imagination this your wife is our square
and when you switch your values right
you're turning it on its head so one of
the things you'll learn later on we
would invest functions it is really easy
way to tell which one is you can test it
by putting a vertical line through it
okay if your vertical line justice
what's that car supposed to be one
output that's a function the heater hits
twice sometimes might multiple times
okay so that's why it's relation okay
that's what functions are